hello and welcome to this video playing
with slaw with black and I have one upon
very early on
it's called the qg am NOT going to keep
the pond most likely people people keep
playing this and I'm not really aware
what the implications are if for is not
not really a great movie I'm against a
six it's now I'm keeping this pawn at
least for a little while
you
looks odd but due to the pollen if all
this is really viable there is no Queen
a form
so now I'm going to get fairly good play
against the center
now usually in such a situation Knight
takes d5 is a threat
didn't quite check it
he really wants this back huh
I mean it's not problem per se few takes
but anyway let's check this a little bit
if I'm
I don't know let's let's do this I just
I should be able to cook I am
okay now my idea is that on Bishop takes
I have c5 but I'm not so sure how good
that is
honestly
half night be three what am I doing here
I got 93 the whole time and I'm not
seeing that that's it's crazy that's
crazy okay
sometimes you really wonder
like the kindergarten tactics a new
tactic is a tactic as a strong word 493
like okay call it a motif if you are
very very fancy about it
crazy stuff
okay no way from no way to keep him from
castling a baby c6 is a way to do it
a queen 3/7 I'm an exchanger but I want
to make my life as easy as possible of
course Queen d7 probably has to play
niya Bishop e2
ya can do that I think wrong about it
and now this one he can Castle because
of rookie Rookie one at the end so
castles Bishop takes pawn takes Queen e2
this Ruby one
didn't really okay anyway for another
tempo
now come on if I'm just an exchange up
and getting rid of all the nights make
sense no Forks no fork for you
no for us actually witness it's it's the
source of this is of course no soup for
you if you know that reference your
good with your TV series so no soup for
you
and here no fog for you I mean actually
it would fit with no spoon where you had
no soup for your reference
but there are there are no spoons and
chance relief yeah no backroom made for
you
you
Queen before next
you
you
don't very little that
to him so what is the thing G for me
you
you
you should take sage five
you
if he takes us Queenie seven
that would force a croon trade
and now he has to trade Queens Queen G
for Queenie form otherwise I'd take the
bishop
you
I can take the take the bishop now
it was still absolutely crazy that it
took me half a minute or more to see
Knight b3 yeah okay so a four is really
not such a great move
you can argue by the way if you play
knight c6 cm or Knight f6 first but I
think this is okay now the idea is to
keep to keep this covered and it's a bit
annoying for white really so he went d5
Knight eighty-five ninety three and I'm
attacking the center and it's not so
easy enough for him to keep at this one
yeah now I'm threatening Knight takes d5
here so if he does that same yeah let's
say we should be too long I can take him
oops I'm sorry
I can take it all right this is the
point that there is this recapture and
yeah Knight takes I take here now take
this one and win basically yeah now I
can just already play Knight b3 of
course crazy it's really crazy it's
giving me a second chance now I take it
yeah idea this is a complete win that I
mean I did not have to take everything
off but it's just like it's very simple
and wins in a technical fashion getting
rid of the Knights is not something that
is a commonly accepted way of playing
that's a but I think in again especially
in blitz when you have little time it's
sometimes advisable if you mean
technically and you can just eliminate
the forks it makes your life a little
bit easier oftentimes okay guys thanks
for watching